entre une photo à mes côtés et non pas
une prolongation de son contrat actuel
c'est important a souligné on va passer
à skis de ce qui est une information
désormais aux fausses informations c'est
la chasse aux fausses d'infos avec vous
antoine feu dans un instant
bonsoir antoine fenaux en soi raphaël
direction l'ukraine avec le retour sous
une nouvelle forme d'une un fox a la
peau dure oui pas question de quillan
mba paix vous l'avez bien compris rafale
mais bien de l'ukraine avec
l'arrestation de hauts gradés
occidentaux en ukraine c'est une info
kz1 qui revient régulièrement depuis le
début de l'invasion russe en ukraine et
ont tout ça on va y revenir mais tout
d'abord sur le dernier exemple en date
donc elle je voulais vous parler c'est
ce tweet que vous allez apercevoir qu'il
illustre on y voit donc un soldat
prisonnier entouré de rouge envoyés sur
sa tête et en dessous et une autre photo
d'un haut gradé américain le tweet lui
il est clair l'amiral américain erik
olsson commandant des forces spéciales
hautement décoré a été capturé à l'
usine azoff stade marioupol publication
retweeter 1 vous le vous le voyez
plusieurs plusieurs milliers de fois à
noter également qu'une autre publication
similaire en espagnol un émanant là une
fois encore d'un contre pro-russe a là
aussi largement circulé vous l'apercevez
retweeté et laïque et comme on dit
plusieurs milliers de fois alors tout
d'abord il faut savoir qui est eric
olson sa biographie est facilement
accessible en ligne sur le site spirit
of america une ong venant en aide aux
américains déployés à l'étranger que ce
soit des hommes des militaires ou bien
des diplomates
déjà premiers détails qui clochent cette
biographie nous dit eric olson est
retraité de la marine américaine et ce
depuis 2011 il a effectivement passé 38
ans dans les forces armées américaines
raphaël voilà pour son profil revenons à
notre photo et que sun a t'il bien été
arrêté à marioupol et bien non vous vous
en doutez rafale et pour le vérifier il
suffit de procéder comme on le fait très
régulièrement ici info ou intox à une
recherche d'image inversée vous en avez
l'habitude avec notre photo et bien et
cette photo on la retrouve notamment sur
cet article du média mais pro
gouvernementale russe ria novosti il
date du 14 avril 2022 le titre que vous
avez que je vais vous montrer ici que je
vais vous traduire
il dit on n'oubliera pas on ne
pardonnera pas article qui fait
référence à une cérémonie qui a lieu eu
lieu le donc le 14 avril 2022 à louhansk
commis en hommage aux victimes des
combats entre les séparatistes pro
russes et l'armée ukraine c'est en 2014
sous notre photo et bien on retrouve une
légende que je vous ai traduit des
prisonniers ukrainien des prisonniers
ukrainien de la garde nationale ont été
amenés à l'événement cérémonie et photos
que l'on trouve aussi sur le site
d'information pro-russe pout nique mais
médias inaccessible on le rappelle en
l'union européenne la capture d'écran
été réalisés je vous le précise par un
média américain et spoutnik qui confirme
également cette cérémonie d'hommage
d'évacuation elle des soldats de
marioupol on l'a beaucoup commentée ici
à france 24 à laquelle la publication
fait référence elle est intervenue un
mois après la prise de ce cliché donc en
résumé vous l'avez compris raphaël eric
olson n'a pas arrêté à marioupol il
s'agit d'une photo d'un prisonnier
ukrainien lors d'une cérémonie russe
donc pas de soldats américains
sur le site d'azf talon le cas d'éric
olson mais ce type d'un phoque ce n'est
n'est pas un nouveau 1 dans cette guerre
vous en avez d'autres exemples oui
souvenez vous je vous en avais déjà
parlé ici à l'occasion de cette
chronique c'était début avril une vidéo
à l'époque avait largement circulé sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est celle ci elle
prétendait montrer l'arrestation de
roger cloutier sous un haut commandant
de l'otan là encore c'était à marioupol
en réalité c'est une vidéo filmée par le
fsb russe qui montre l arrestation d'un
tatars de crimée qui combattaient pour
les ukrainiens et puis plus récemment et
bien c'est l'arrestation d'un au général
carrade canadien là encore l usine
d'azov talent qui avaient circulé trevor
cadieux c'est c'est son nom c'est avait
alimenté tous les fantasmes car il s'est
effectivement rendu en ukraine pour
combattre l'armée russe après avoir été
renvoyé de l'armée canadienne pour
inconduite sexuelle selon l'armée
canadienne je cite son arrestation elle
n'a jamais été confirmées ni par l'armée
russe ni par aucun document auquel nous
avons pu avoir accès dont vous voyez
technique identique prétendants
l'arrestation de hauts gradés
occidentaux est en tout cas c'est une
technique largement utilisé par les
comptes pro russe l'objectif on le
comprend et bien c'est de prouver une
implication directe des occidentaux dans
le conflit et bien sûr aussi alimenter
les faits d'armes de l'armée russe mais
avec encore une fois une victime eh bien
c'est la vérité